well for the first time this morning a
House committee led by Democrats will
question a member of president Trump's
cabinet acting Attorney General Matt
Whittaker took control of the Justice
Department three months ago Paula Reed
is at the White House with how both
sides are preparing for this hearing
Paula good morning good morning here at
the White House officials are gearing up
for a lengthy battle as House Democrats
launched dozens of investigations into
the administration but Democrats have
already risked over playing their hand
yesterday they nearly lost their star
witness acting Attorney General Matthew
Whitaker when the chairman of the
committee threatened Whitaker with an
unprecedented subpoena if he did not
answer every question about the Russia
investigation and questions about
conversations he's had with the
president even though those
conversations are protected by executive
privilege
now Whitaker threatened to back out of
the hearing if the threat was not
dropped and under political pressure the
committee backed off now Whitaker has
been preparing for this hearing by
participating in hours long mock
hearings this morning though Democrats
revealed they plan to ask Whitaker about
world patent marketing a company he was
involved in which was accused of fraud
now the president continues to try to
paint these hearings as overreach
repeatedly calling these investigations
quote harassment Whitaker is unlikely to
be in the job too much longer he is
expected to be replaced by William Barr
the president's nominee to be the next
Attorney General his nomination is
moving through the Senate but some
Democrats have expressed concern about
how transparent he will be with the
special council's final report Gail all
right Paula thank you very much